Le 12 novembre 2004, les obsèques
du président Yasser Arafat,
se déroulent en Cisjordanie, à Ramallah,
la capitale des Palestiniens.
100 000 personnes sont présentes pour
accueillir la dépouille de leur raïs,
mort à l'âge de 75 ans.
Celui que l'on surnomme
"L'homme aux sept vies",
s'est éteint quelques jours plus tôt
à l'hôpital Percy de Clamart, en France.
Cette disparition soudaine reste
encore aujourd'hui entourée de mystère.
Ce jour là, ce n'est pas seulement
un chef que les Palestiniens enterrent,
mais un mythe,
l'incarnation du rêve palestinien.
Un long combat qu'il a entamé
un demi siècle plus tôt.
Arafat est né au Caire,
en Egypte, le 24 août 1929.
Toute sa jeunesse, il la passe
dans la capitale égyptienne,
où il poursuit des études d'ingénieur.
Son diplôme en poche, il se
lance dans l'action politique.
Sa véritable histoire commence
à la fin des années 50,
lorsqu'il crée le Fatah,
un mouvement destiné à représenter,
les réfugiés palestiniens qui vivent
dans les camps des pays arabes voisins.
Nous n'aimons pas le combat, la guerre.
Mais la personne
qui a été chassée de chez elle,
est obligée et a le droit de combattre.
Son mentor sera Gamal Abdel Nasser,
qui, avec d'autres officiers,
vient de renverser
la monarchie égyptienne.
Grâce au soutien de Nasser
et des Soviétiques,
Il fédère en 1964 les différents
mouvements palestiniens au sein de l'OLP,
l'Organisation de libération de la Palestine,
dont il devient le président.
Keffieh sur la tête, vareuse kaki
et pistolet à la ceinture,
il endosse les habits
du chef révolutionnaire.
Un nouveau mythe vient de naître.
Il y avait Che Guevara,
il y a désormais Arafat.
En 1967, après la guerre des Six Jours,
qui voit la défaite de plusieurs
pays arabes face à Israël,
Yasser Arafat installe ses camps
d'entraînement en Jordanie.
C'est de là que ces fedayin préparent
des opérations commandos contre Israël.
Recours à la violence,
prise d'otages et détournement d'avions.
Le 6 septembre 1970, trois avions de
compagnies européennes et américaines,
sont détournés sur la base de Zarka,
au Nord-Est de la Jordanie.
Les otages sont retenus
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport,
et les ravisseurs font
exploser les avions vides,
devant les caméras du monde entier.
Ulcéré par le comportement des Palestiniens,
le roi Hussein de Jordanie
déclenche le 12 septembre 1970,
les hostilités contre les fedayin de l'OLP.
Les combats connus
sous le nom de Septembre noir,
causent la mort
de plusieurs milliers de personnes.
Arafat et ses combattants
n'ont qu'un seul choix,
fuir au Liban, où l'histoire
ne tarde pas à se répéter.
Mais la violence se poursuit.
En septembre 1972,
durant les Jeux de Munich,
un commando palestinien pénètre
dans le village olympique,
et prend en otage 9 athlètes israéliens.
La police allemande intervient.
C'est un carnage.
Les athlètes sont tous tués.
La condamnation internationale est unanime.
Au Liban, devenu la nouvelle terre
d'asile des Palestiniens,
les camps de réfugiés se multiplient
et très vite,
ils servent de base pour lancer des
opérations militaires contre les Israéliens.
Mais Yasser Arafat va comprendre
que la diplomatie peut être un atout.
En 1974, l'Organisation
des Nations Unies reconnaît l'OLP,
comme seul représentant
du peuple palestinien.
En 1975, au Liban, leur présence
entraîne le pays dans la guerre civile,
et ils poursuivent leur combat
contre l'Etat hébreu.
En 1982, Israël lance
l'opération Paix en Galilée.
Les chars Merkava pénètrent au Sud-Liban,
et s'installent aux portes de Beyrouth.
Yasser Arafat et les siens se retrouvent
assiégés dans la capitale libanaise.
Il échappe plusieurs fois à la mort.
Nous subissons une invasion.
Nous sommes face à une agression,
à une occupation israélienne.
Il n'y a pas de solution
concernant une issue politique.
Le 30 août 1982, Yasser Arafat
et ses hommes doivent quitter Beyrouth.
Ils essaient de faire bonne figure,
mais le cœur n'y est pas.
Sous la protection
des parachutistes français,
dépêchés par le président
François Mitterrand,
ils embarquent sur un bateau grec
et sont évacués vers Tunis.
À bord, le chef est pensif, avec
probablement de l'amertume au fond de lui.
Il sait qu'il a perdu une grande bataille,
mais une nouvelle fois,
il est sain et sauf.
Seul réconfort, l'accueil que lui réserve
la population dans la capitale tunisienne.
Mais la lutte armée se poursuit.
Le 1ᵉʳ octobre 1985,
des F15 israéliens,
bombardent le quartier général
de l'OLP à Tunis.
Le bilan est lourd, 68 morts.
Yasser Arafat a de la chance,
il était absent ce jour-là.
Ils ont préparé cette embuscade,
pour m'assassiner. Mais pas seulement.
Aujourd'hui ils ont été jusqu'à
bombarder ma propre maison.
L'homme a la réputation d'être très secret.
L'habitude de la clandestinité, sans doute.
Le 17 juillet 1990, à Tunis.
Il épouse à l'âge de 61 ans,
dans la plus grande discrétion,
sa collaboratrice,
Souha, de 34 ans sa cadette,
et de confession chrétienne.
Mais sa fameuse chance
ne semble pas le quitter.
Le 8 avril 1992, il échappe
une nouvelle fois à la mort,
lorsque son avion,
un Antonov 26, parti du Soudan,
s'écrase dans le désert libyen.
Les passagers sont tués.
Lui en sort indemne.
Un miracle qui étonne le colonel
Kadhafi venu lui rendre visite.
Des négociations secrètes
sous l'égide de Bill Clinton,
aboutissent aux accords d'Oslo,
et à la poignée de main historique
du 13 septembre 1993.
Yasser Arafat,
Yitzhak Rabin et Shimon Pérès,
côte à côte sur le perron
de la Maison-Blanche.
L'année suivante, les deux Israéliens
et le Palestinien,
reçoivent à Oslo,
le prix Nobel de la paix.
Pour avoir signé cette paix,
Yitzhak Rabin sera assassiné
quelques mois plus tard,
par un extrémiste israélien.
Le 1ᵉʳ juillet 1994, parce qu'il
a choisi la voie du dialogue,
Yasser Arafat peut enfin
retourner à Gaza,
pour préparer les fondations
d'un futur Etat.
Deux ans plus tard,
les premières élections le portent
à la présidence de l'Autorité palestinienne.
À l'intérieur de leur propre camp,
les Palestiniens sont divisés.
Pour le Hamas, mouvement islamiste
très implanté dans la bande de Gaza,
Arafat est un traître
qui a abdiqué devant Israël.
Les relations se dégradent
encore plus quand il déclare,
la fin de la lutte armée
contre l'Etat hébreu.
Un complot pour l'assassiner
est déjoué.
Sept Palestiniens sont arrêtés.
La chance est encore avec lui.
Au fil des ans, les critiques
augmentent contre un Raïs,
de plus en plus contesté
au sein de son propre camp.
Lui et ses fidèles
sont accusés de s'enrichir.
La révolte gronde
dans les territoires occupés.
Elles éclatent lorsque Ariel Sharon
visite l'esplanade
des Mosquées à Jérusalem.
Une provocation qui déclenche
la seconde Intifada,
que Yasser Arafat n'arrive pas
ou ne veut pas maîtriser.
La situation se dégrade en 2001, notamment
en Israël où les attentats se multiplient.
Devenu Premier ministre de l'État d'Israël,
Ariel Sharon,
l'ancien général, l'ennemi intime,
l'accuse de soutenir des opérations kamikazes.
Il donne l'ordre d'encercler la Mouqata'a,
les bureaux de la présidence palestinienne.
Et de détruire petit à petit ce palais,
qui ne tient debout que par miracle.
Durant 3 ans, Yasser Arafat reste prisonnier
dans ce réduit de quelques mètres carrés.
Assiégé par les chars israéliens,
Yasser Arafat ne peut avoir
aucun contact avec l'extérieur.
En octobre 2004, il est isolé.
Et les rumeurs sur son état de
santé font craindre le pire,
notamment à sa femme Souha
et à sa fille Zahwa.
J'essaie de l'appeler plusieurs fois
pour dire bonjour,
pour que Zahwa lui parle parce
qu'on lui parlait tous les jours.
On me dit qu'il a une grippe,
qu'il dort.
Le lendemain, il a une grosse grippe,
il dort.
Il a 40 de fièvre,
il ne peut pas se lever.
J'ai douté parce que personne ne
me disait ce qu'il se passait.
Quand je l'ai eu, j'ai senti...
Sa voix très tremblante.
Et puis il m'a dit : "Comment vas-tu ?
Tu sais que moi je t'aime
beaucoup et j'aime Zahwa.
Il ne dit jamais :
"Je t'aime beaucoup et j'aime Zahwa."
Jamais au téléphone.
C'est un homme très pudique,
très formel, très austère.
Il ne dit pas ses émotions,
il ne dévoile pas ses sentiments.
Il n'était pas normal.
Ce n'était pas le Abou Ammar
que l'on connaissait.
Il avait maigri. Beaucoup.
Et il était faible.
Il était vraiment très mal en point.
Le lendemain, il ne pouvait
pas se lever, j'ai appelé...
Pour dire que j'allais arrivé,
il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas.
J'arrive vers 7H30.
Je suis montée chez lui
et puis il m'a regardé comme ça...
En essayant de me reconnaître ou pas,
mais après il m'a reconnu,
et il m'a dit : "Souha, j'ai une petite
grippe, ça va passer, t'inquiète pas.
Le problème c'est qu'il parle
après le fil conducteur des pensées.
Et ça ne continue pas.
C'était le dix du mois de Ramadan.
Je lui rendais visite.
On m'a dit que le président
souffrait d'une maladie grave,
et on m'a demandé de lui conseiller
de ne pas jeûner à cause de cette maladie.
J'ai essayé d'en apprendre plus.
Les médecins m'ont dit qu'ils n'arrivaient
pas encore à déterminer clairement,
le mal dont il souffrait.
Ils disaient juste que c'était grave.
Le problème était que quand on leur parlait,
quand on leur demandait
comment allait le président,
ils restaient discret,
ils ne nous donnaient aucune information.
Du coup, je pensais que quelque
chose d'anormal se tramait.
Dans le huis clos de ce bâtiment à peine
rénové, le seul encore debout,
les médecins palestiniens et ceux
dépêchés par la Tunisie et l'Egypte,
sont très inquiets.
Devant les photographes,
Yasser Arafat essaie de faire bonne figure.
Mais il dépérit à vue d'oeil.
Une seule solution : Qu'il soit
soigner dans un hôpital à l'étranger.
J'ai eu un dîner avec Javier Solana, le
commissaire européen aux Affaires étrangères.
Dans ses bureaux à Bruxelles.
Il a reçu un coup de fil et il nous
a dit qu'Arafat était très malade.
Solana voulait que je demande à Sharon
de lui donner l'autorisation,
de quitter Ramallah pour la France.
J'ai appelé Sharon et il m'a dit :
"Il a seulement attrapé un coup de froid."
Sharon a ajouté que s'il était
autorisé à voyager en Europe,
en France avec la cuisine française,
de l'air frais,
il allait se régénérer et il reprendrait
forcément ses voyages ici et là.
Il a donc refusé.
Puis j'ai eu un coup de fil d'un
Palestinien que je connais très bien.
Et il m'a dit la chose suivante :
"Si vous ne lui permettait pas de partir,
il mourra dans la Mouqata'a."
Ça fait 2000 ans que vous
essayez d'expliquer,
que vous n'avez pas crucifié Jesus.
Pour les prochains 2000 ans,
vous allez devoir expliquer,
que vous n'êtes pas responsable
de la mort d'Arafat.
J'ai rappelé, Sharon a réfléchi
quelques minutes,
et m'a dit d'appeler Mr Solana
et de lui donner l'autorisation.
La question est posée à la France.
Il y a une relation cordiale entre,
Jacques Chirac et Yasser Arafat,
Il l'appelait d'ailleurs le docteur Chirac.
Et donc pour des raisons humanitaires,
la réponse est favorable.
Je rentre à la Mouqata'a.
C'est assez étrange,
une ambiance assez silencieuse.
On m'emmène dans sa chambre
qui est sur le même palier,
un petit peu plus loin,
une petite chambre qui se trouve...
Dans mon souvenir,
sans fenêtre avec avec un petit lit.
Et je vois Arafat
qui est assis au bord du lit,
dans cette tenue
avec une fermeture éclair, bleu clair.
Je me mets vraiment en face de lui
à sa hauteur, je me baisse.
Je me souviens lui avoir touché le genou,
et avoir été marqué par la maigreur,
en quelque sorte de son genou.
Je lui ai dit quelques mots
en arabe pour lui dire,
qu'il va partir en France.
L'hélicoptère Jordanien doit venir
pour nous récupérer pour aller en Jordanie.
Il ne pouvait pas tenir.
Il pouvait marcher avec 4 personnes.
Quand on est descendus,
vous avez vu la scène ?
Des milliers de gens pleuraient.
Et quand il a fait les bisous aux gens...
Ça nous a pris seulement une petite demi
heure pour aller en Jordanie,
où il y avait un avion militaire français,
que le président Chirac
avait envoyé, équipé.
Le pauvre, il faisait des bisous.
Alors je suis montée, moi, son directeur
du cabinet et un garde du corps.
C'est dans un hélicoptère
médicalisé de l'armée française,
que le président palestinien est transporté
à l'hôpital militaire Percy, à Clamart,
dans la banlieue parisienne.
Sur les toits, dans la rue,
gendarmes et policiers veillent à la sécurité
d'un des hommes les plus menacés de la planète.
L'établissement est devenu
une véritable forteresse.
Yasser Arafat ne peut plus marcher,
mais il est conscient.
Sa femme Souha, est inquiète.
Elle accompagne le brancard
jusqu'à l'étage réservé,
interdit aux personnes non autorisées.
J'ai une chambre communicante à côté.
Des chambres normales,
ils ont mis pleins de médicaments.
Les trois premiers jours étaient bien.
Il se rappelait de choses,
c'était bien, on lui parlait.
Il parlait avec Chirac.
C'est Chirac qui m'a appelé.
Je lui ai passé Arafat
et il a commencé petit à petit,
à perdre tout ce qui est dans son ventre.
Il a commencé à crier,
à faire des scènes de folie,
il criait sur les gens et sur moi aussi.
C'est incroyable !
Je suis venue après qu'il a crié,
je me suis approchée de lui,
il m'a regardé, il a commencé à pleurer.
Ils sont venus et ils l'ont attaché
au lit pour qu'il ne s'énerve pas.
Pour lui donner un calmant.
Et il est parti en réanimation.
Une vingtaine de médecins militaires
de toutes les spécialités,
sont penchés sur Yasser Arafat.
Les analyses ne donnent rien,
et les réunions se succèdent pour
que chacun tente d'apporter un diagnostic.
Plusieurs spécialistes civils
sont appelés à y participer.
Parmi les nombreux prélèvements faits,
aucun n'était positif,
ni pour une bactérie, ni pour un virus,
ni pour un parasite.
En réanimation arrivait
parfois des malades,
qui étaient en général des personnalités
importantes africaines,
qui avaient séjourné dans leur pays,
dans les fins fonds de la forêt,
et qui revenaient malades.
Et ils faisaient des ennuis avec des
insuffisance rénale,
des insuffisance hépatique,
des états sévère,
on cherchait quelque chose
d'infectieux, sans ne rien trouver.
Nos patrons nous disaient :
"vous savez...
Vous ne pouvez pas exclure
qu'on ait empoisonné ces sujets,
et qu'ils aient absorbé un quelque
chose que nous ne savons pas déterminer."
Par analogie, je ne peux pas exclure
complètement que...
Éventuellement une substance,
un empoisonnement ou quelque chose,
ait pu être administré.
Souha Arafat commence à réaliser
que l'état de santé de son mari,
est peut être dû à un empoisonnement.
Alors, dans le plus grand secret,
elle téléphone à son amie Suzanne Moubarak,
l'épouse du président égyptien,
l'un des plus grands soutiens d'Arafat,
pour lui demander de l'aide.
Elle sait que l'Egypte entretient
des relations très étroites avec Israël.
J'étais en contact avec Moubarak et sa femme,
et le chef de la sécurité
des services secrets égyptiens.
Et il me disait qu'il ne fallait
pas parler de la situation de Yasser.
parce que nous voulons garder le secret.
On n'a pas envie de dévoiler ce
qu'il se passe parce qu'on est en train,
de discuter avec les Israéliens,
s'ils ont l'antidote, comme ils ont
donné à Khaled Mechaal, le chef du Hamas.
Khaled Mechaal, le voici.
Considéré comme terroriste par Israël
et la communauté internationale,
sa tentative d'assassinat avait
déclenché une grave crise diplomatique,
entre la Jordanie et Israël.
En 1997 à Amman,
la capitale jordanienne,
deux agents israéliens lui injectent
une dose de poison dans le cou.
Khaled Mechaal sombre dans le coma.
Les espions sont arrêtés.
Le roi Hussein est furieux.
Il menace de remettre
en cause le traité de paix.
Israël est obligé de livrer l'antidote.
Mechaal est sauvé. Pour lui, pas de doute,
Arafat a été empoisonné.
Il m'a dit :
"J'étais dans le coma plusieurs jours,
et quand ils ont emmené l'antidote,
en trois secondes, je me suis réveillé.
Essaie de trouver l'antidote."
Souha est désormais persuadée
que Yasser Arafat a été empoisonné.
Elle interdit les visites
et exige des communiqués laconiques,
sur le véritable état
de santé de son mari.
L'état de santé du président
Yasser Arafat,
ne s'est pas aggravé.
Monsieur Chirac est venu parce que
j'ai refusé de faire un communiqué,
pour parler de ce qui se passait.
Il voulait que je dévoile
qu'il était dans le coma.
Mais je ne voulais pas devoiler
qu'il était dans le coma,
parce que je ne voulais pas
que les gens qui l'ont empoisonné,
qu'ils sachent où on en est arrivé,
à quel stade...
En réalité, dans les coulisses
se joue un étrange ballet diplomatique.
C'est la succession
de Yasser Arafat qui est en jeu.
En pleine nuit débarque
à Paris une délégation  conduite,
par les principaux
responsables palestiniens,
qui souhaitent rencontrer leur président.
Souha refuse qu'ils pénètrent
dans la chambre de son mari.
Et la raison d'Etat est la plus forte.
La France a toujours affiché
un appui fidèle à Yasser Arafat,
conformément à sa tradition diplomatique
initiée par le général de Gaulle en 1967,
et poursuivie par ses successeurs.
Jacques Chirac qui s'inquiète
du vide du pouvoir après la mort d'Arafat,
qu'il sait inéluctable, invite les membres
de la délégation palestinienne à l'Elysée.
Tous sont ensuite reçus par le ministre
français des Affaires étrangères.
La question est posée sur le plan politique
de savoir ce qui va se passer après.
Yasser Arafat est toujours vivant.
Nous espérons jusqu'au dernier moment
qu'il pourra se rétablir,
mais néanmoins il est affaibli,
et donc la question dans son propre
camp se pose de sa succession,
de comment les choses vont se passer.
C'est assez légitime que...
Dans ce processus de paix tellement
difficile, tellement fragile,
tellement incertain, avec des allers-retours
depuis des dizaines d'années que...
ceux qui souhaite la paix
entre Israéliens et Palestiniens,
ceux qui souhaitent une paix fondée sur
deux Etats indépendants qui se respectent,
se préoccupent de savoir ce qui
va se passer du côté palestinien.
Tout le monde s'en foutait d'Arafat.
Je vous le dis !
Tout le monde voulait voir
quelle sera sa situation après à Arafat.
Ils ont amener le président du Conseil
national palestinien,
c'est à dire le Parlement,
pour qu'il voient si...
Parce qu'il y a des lois, si le président
est capable de régner ou pas.
J'ai dit : "Pas question !"
Ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui est devenu sénile.
Il a peut être été empoisonné
et personne ne touche à Arafat !
Et là, j'ai tenu tête,
et j'ai interdit tout
le leadership palestinien d'y entrer.
J'ai laissé seulement le premier
ministre palestinien Abou Alaa,
qui a perdu confiance quand
il a vu Arafat troué de partout.
J'aurais souhaité ne pas
l'avoir vu dans cet état,
car à ce moment là, j'ai réalisé
qu'Abou Ammar vivait là ses derniers moments.
Je l'ai appelé très fort.
Abou Ammar !
mais il n'a pas répondu.
À ce moment là,
j'ai compris qu'il était déjà parti.
Et qu'il ne reviendrait pas.
Que Dieu soit clément avec lui.
Normalement,
quand quelqu'un est dans le coma,
On lui met quelque chose
ou il aime, ou il déteste,
pour faire un choc.
Alors j'ai dit : "Vous voulez qu'on
amène les les discours du chanoine ?"
On va ne pas quand même pas faire ça,
en rigolant.
Et puis j'ai envoyé un ami pour,
amener les chants du Coran.
Souha de religion chrétienne, espère encore
en écoutant les prières musulmanes.
Mais au fond d'elle-même, elle sent
que le vieux chef a perdu son dernier combat.
Monsieur Yasser Arafat,
président de l'Autorité palestinienne,
est décédé à l'hôpital d'instruction
des armées Percy à Clamart,
le 11 novembre 2004 à 3h30.
Avant les obsèques nationales
dans son pays,
les honneurs lui sont rendus
sur la base militaire de Villacoublay.
À côté de sa veuve
et de la délégation palestinienne,
le Premier ministre Jean-Pierre Raffarin
représente le gouvernement français.
La Garde républicaine également présente,
joue la sonnerie aux morts.
Un message destiné à montrer
l'attachement de la France,
au peuple palestinien et au monde arabe.
Le cercueil est ensuite transporté
dans un Airbus de la République française,
jusqu'au Caire.
L'égypte offre au président palestinien
défunt des funérailles grandioses.
En présence de très nombreux chefs d'État.
Souha et sa fille, alors âgée de neuf ans,
assistent à la cérémonie.
Aujourd'hui, le corps de l'ancien président
palestinien repose à Ramallah,
dans un mausolée érigé dans l'enceinte
même du palais reconstruit,
où il avait été assiégé durant trois ans.
Palestiniens et touristes arabes
viennent s'y recueillir.
Pour lui rendre hommage, mais aussi
parce que la mort de Yasser Arafat,
suscite encore depuis une décennie
de nombreuses interrogations.
C'est sur les bords du lac Léman,
en Suisse, que va naître la polémique.
À la demande de Souha Arafat,
un laboratoire va analyser les effets
personnels de son mari.
Je donne au laboratoire, c'est l'Université
de Lausanne pour tout ce qui est,
des études scientifiques
et nucléaires de Lausanne.
Et je donne tout.
Il y avait des sous vêtements où il y
avait des taches de sang minime,
et des tâche de ce
qui semblait être de l'urine.
Et puis par ailleurs, sur un
chapeau, sur un bonnet,
on a retrouvé quelques poils.
On avait des valeurs.
Si je donne les chiffres,
on était aux alentours de quatre, cinq,
voire jusqu'à dix millibecquerel.
Et puis on a mesuré jusqu'à 180
sur la tâche d'urine par exemple.
De là est venu,
l'hypothèse d'une possible
intoxication au polonium.
Et c'est là qu'ils ont trouvé
des traces de polonium sur le sang,
l'urine, la sueur et les cheveux.
Pourtant, au moment de sa disparition,
des analyses sur la radioactivité
des métaux,
avaient été effectuées par l'Institut de
recherche criminelle de la Gendarmerie nationale,
et par le Laboratoire de contrôle
radio toxicologique des armées.
Les tests se sont révélés négatifs.
Ils ont mesuré qu'un certain
type d'éléments radioactifs,
c'est à dire ceux qui sont capables
d'émettre des particules gamma,
donc les émissions alpha ne sont
pas mesurés avec ce genre de mesure.
On ne peut pas en vouloir à l'hôpital
Percy d'avoir demandé ce genre de mesure,
parce qu'on était en 2004, personne ne
pensait à un empoisonnement au polonium.
Entre temps, il y a eu l'affaire de cet
espion russe, Litvinenko en Angleterre,
où il a été démontré qu'il avait été victime
d'une intoxication aiguë par du polonium 210.
Alexandre Litvinenko, c'est lui.
Avant la détérioration de son état de santé.
En 2006, il meurt à Londres après
3 semaines d'atroces souffrances.
Les médecins découvrent
du polonium 210 dans ses urines,
en pratiquant des analyses
avec des rayons alpha,
très peu employées dans les hôpitaux.
L'enquête démontre qu'il a été
irradié par deux agents russes,
qui ont versé une goutte de polonium
dans sa tasse de thé.
Le polonium, une matière hautement
radioactive, très rare et très dangereuse.
Il fallait considérer
très sérieusement cette hypothèse,
et donc la proposition
formulée à madame Arafat,
de devoir contrôler cette hypothèse,
par une analyse directement
sur la dépouille de Monsieur Arafat,
donc la nécessité d'une exhumation.
Devant l'hypothèse d'un empoisonnement au
polonium émise par les laboratoires suisses,
la veuve de Yasser Arafat,
qui a également la nationalité française,
dépose le 31 juillet 2012 au tribunal
de grande instance de Nanterre,
une plainte contre X.
En novembre 2012,
l'autorité palestinienne accepte l'exhumation
de la dépouille de Yasser Arafat.
À Ramallah, des bâches sont tendues
devant le mausolée.
Trois équipes scientifiques sont présentes.
La première, Suisse,
à la demande de madame Arafat.
La deuxième Russe mandatée
par l'Autorité palestinienne,
une troisième Française
accompagnée de trois juges,
parce qu'une enquête a été ouverte
par la justice française pour assassinat.
Alors on avait à peu près 80 kilos
de matériel de mesure sophistiqué.
On avait une équipe qui comprenait
des légistes, des toxicologues,
une anthropologue et aussi
des spécialistes de radio physique.
À priori, chaque équipe cherchait
à vérifier cette hypothèse.
Est-ce que dans les ossements, on trouverait
des quantités élevé de polonium ?
Nous on avait des spécialistes
de cette question "polonium".
Des gens qui connaissent le polonium,
qui ont déjà procédé à des exhumations,
et qui ont déjà mesuré du polonium
dans les ossements.
Ces 2 personnes étaient
dans notre équipe.
Ce qui nous a étonné,
c'est que dans l'équipe française,
il n'y avait pas de spécialistes du polonium.
Dans l'équipe russe, il y avait,
mais pas dans l'équipe française.
Avant d'ouvrir la tombe,
on a documenté la situation radiologique,
avec des Compteur Geiger,
des moniteurs de contamination de surface.
Une fois qu'on a ouvert la tombe,
avant même de toucher quoi que ce soit,
on a documenté,
la radioactivité
qui se trouvait à proximité.
Si on veut pouvoir dire quoi que ce soit,
il faut documenter tout l'environnement
parce qu'on mesure des petites quantités,
quand on mesure des petites quantités,
on se posera la question de savoir,
est-ce que c'est naturel
ou est-ce que c'est artificiel ?
La question est alors posée.
Est-ce la terre qui a contaminé
naturellement le corps ?
Ou bien est-ce le cadavre
irradié par un empoisonnement,
qui a pollué le sol sur lequel il repose
comme le veut la religion musulmane ?
Tout le monde était autour.
Nous sommes descendus dans la tombe.
L'équipe palestinienne a perforé
un trou dans la dalle de la tombe.
Ensuite, on y a mis notre tuyau
pour collecter l'air,
et mesurer le radon à cet endroit là.
Monsieur Arafat été positionné comme ça,
avec sa tête ici, ses pieds ici,
les échantillons de terre
que nous avons prélevés,
l'élément le plus éloigné se trouvait ici,
c'est l'échantillon de terre
qu'on a appelé de référence.
Et puis on a pris un autre échantillon
qui se trouvait sous la cavité abdominale,
qui avait visiblement été souillé
par des liquides biologiques.
Les analyses sont claires.
L'endroit où le sol est le plus contaminé
est bien sous l'estomac du défunt,
où la mesure est 17 fois supérieure
à celle relevée loin du corps.
Yasser Arafat aurait donc souillé la terre
parce qu'il était irradié par le polonium,
qu'il aurait ingurgité.
Une fois que la tombe était ouverte,
voilà à quoi ressemblait le corps.
C'est un dessin qui a été fait
par notre anthropologue.
Chaque équipe a reçu 20 échantillons,
exactement les mêmes, enfin façons de parler.
Par exemple chacun avait 2 côtes.
C'était pas les mêmes côtes,
chacun avait une partie du sternum,
une vertèbre, chacun
du cuir chevelu...
Pour éviter toute contestation,
chaque étape du processus
est filmée par les experts suisses,
qui jouent la transparence
et veulent rester irréprochables,
dans leur démarche scientifique.
Les ossements de Yasser Arafat
sont analysés en laboratoire.
Ici, une de ses vertèbres.
Ils vont jusqu'au bout de leur enquête
dans l'infiniment petit,
et du polonium dans
le squelette de Yasser Arafat,
Ils en trouve beaucoup.
Beaucoup plus que la moyenne répertoriée
dans les publications scientifiques.
Les Suisses ont la valeur la plus élevée.
Mais si on regarde les deuxième valeur
plus élevées entre Suisses et Russes,
il n'y a pas tellement de différence.
Ensuite, entre Suisses, Russes et Français,
on trouve des valeurs
très proches les unes des autres,
mais qui sont toutes clairement en dessous,
de ce qu'on a pu observer
dans des cas classiques.
À la lecture des résultats,
les experts suisses découvrent
que leurs soupçons sont fondés.
Les analyses démontrent que le
squelette du chef palestinien contient,
suivant les os,
20 fois plus de polonium que la normale.
Pour les Suisses, il s'agit de polonium
artificiel fabriqué par l'homme.
Pour les experts français, nous avons eu
accès à leurs conclusions,
elles sont catégoriques :
Arafat n'est pas mort empoisonné.
Le polonium trouvé dans le squelette
est d'origine environnementale.
Le rapport français élimine l'hypothèse,
de l'intoxication au polonium.
Pour nous, cela nous paraît
un peu simpliste,
et pas démontré par les mesures
qui ont été faites.
On ne peut pas accepter cette explication.
Et la deuxième explication qui est
avancée par le rapport des Français,
c'est de dire mais de toute façon
ce n'est pas compliqué,
Monsieur Arafat a fait une gastro entérite,
une infection intestinale.
cette infection intestinale a mal
tourné mais si vous voulez,
là on tombe un peu des nues
parce que 8 ans après,
on trouve l'explication magique,
auquel ne sont pas parvenus
tous les experts consultés par Percy.
Si on veut aller plus loin,
c'est la phase de l'enquête,
c'est la phase de la police, c'est la
phase des investigations historiques...
Il faut aller plus loin.
Alors qu'à Paris l'instruction
judiciaire est en cours,
à Ramallah,
siège du gouvernement palestinien,
les investigations se poursuivent.
C'est cet homme discret
qui en connaît tous les secrets.
Ancien chef des services de renseignement
et homme de confiance d'Arafat,
le général Tawfik Tirawi est aujourd'hui à la
tête de la commission d'enquête palestinienne,
sur la mort de son chef.
Dès le décès d'Abou Ammar,
j'ai formé un comité d'enquête
au sein des renseignements généraux,
et nous avons commencé à procéder à des
investigations dans le milieu qui l'entourait.
Nous avions conclu qu'il y régnait
une ambiance malsaine.
Pas sécuritaire du tout dans
la façon de protéger le président.
Il y avait négligence,
dans son dispositif de protection par
rapport au lieu dans lequel il se trouvait,
mais aussi concernant la nourriture.
Ramallah, d'autres enquêteurs
procèdent à des investigations.
Il s'agit des Français dépêchés par les trois
juges d'instruction du tribunal de Nanterre,
qui conduisent l'enquête pour assassinat.
Contactés par nos soins, ils n'ont pas
souhaité s'exprimer sur cette affaire.
Selon nos informations, ils ont interrogé
une vingtaine de témoins palestiniens.
Dès qu'ils demandaient à voir quelqu'un,
nous faisions en sorte qu'ils soient là.
C'était ses gardes personnels,
ceux du service de la logistique,
le responsable de la cuisine,
et ceux qui préparaient les repas.
Si Abou Ammar a été empoisonné,
comme le disent les rapports médicaux,
cela veut dire que l'outil
du crime ou le criminel,
fait partie des gens qui ont pu
avoir accès à Abou Ammar.
Mais les premiers bénéficiaires de la
disparition de Yasser Arafat,
sont sans contestation
les Israéliens et Israël.
Vous savez qui est le président
de cette commission d'enquête ?
Tawfik Tirawi,
la sécurité générale en Cisjordanie,
avec à sa tête le très
célèbre Tawfik Tirawi,
était devenu une organisation terroriste.
Imaginez ça ! Les services secrets français,
qui se transforment
en une organisation terroriste.
C'est une plaisanterie
quand vous y pensez !
Israël n'a pas tué Arafat ?
Mais non ! Depuis des années, on sait qu'à
chaque fois qu'il se passe quelque chose,
nous sommes toujours
accusés par les Palestiniens.
Et par de nombreux pays.
Des pays arabes.
Nous sommes toujours les responsables.
Yasser Arafat, événement après événement,
mois après mois,
année après année, n'a rien fait,
absolument rien pour arrêter le flux
de terrorisme contre le peuple israélien.
Dès le début de l'Intifada,
jusqu'en avril 2002,
nous avons déploré 450 décès
pour la plupart des civils.
Les kamikazes étaient nombreux.
Ils ont tué plus de 90% des victimes,
à cause d'opérations
préparées en Cisjordanie.
En avril 2002, lors du dernier
attentat dans le parc hôtel de Netanya.
Nous avons perdu 30 personnes
pendant les fêtes de Pâques.
Les gens étaient attablés.
Il y a eu 150 blessés.
Nous nous sommes dit : "Ça suffit !"
Plus jamais ça !
Lors de la réunion du cabinet,
le lendemain de cette attaque,
l'armée est venue avec une proposition,
qui était celle de réoccuper
les villes palestiniennes.
Du coup, nous avons réoccupé
la ville de Ramallah,
et comme nous étions
dans les environs de la Mouqata'a,
la décision au plus haut niveau
politique a été de l'encercler,
afin d'isoler Arafat
et de lui interdire tout mouvement.
Nous n'avions pas l'intention
d'en faire plus.
Par contre, Sharon a pris plaisir à voir
Arafat bloqué dans cette petite surface,
et de temps en temps, il demandait
à l'armée qui encerclait la Mouqata'a,
de s'approcher encore plus,
pour détruire un autre mur,
un autre immeuble,
afin qu'il soit isolé de plus en plus.
Je trouve, tout comme mon gouvernement,
qu'Arafat est un obstacle à la paix.
Arafat a choisi la stratégie de la terreur.
Le président Bush a lui même
pensé qu'Arafat,
ne faisait pas partie de la solution,
mais plutôt du problème.
J'appelle le peuple palestinien
à élire de nouveaux dirigeants.
Des dirigeants non compromis
par le terrorisme.
Pour George W.Bush et Ariel Sharon,
l'élimination physique du chef
palestinien n'est pas envisagée.
Pourtant, l'armée a bien imaginé
au moins une fois,
de lancer une opération
contre Yasser Arafat.
En 2002, dans une de nos réunions,
les militaires nous ont proposé une idée.
Un plan pour kidnapper Arafat.
Un commando entrerait à la Mouqata'a,
le prendrait par le col,
et le ramènerait dans un lieu où il
ne pourrait faire du mal à personne.
Une des questions que Sharon
a posé au chef militaire de l'époque,
qui est maintenant ministre de la Défense.
était : Quelle était la probabilité qu'Arafat
soit tué durant cette opération ?
Et la réponse fut qu'elle était élevée.
La Mouqata'a était pleine d'hommes armés.
Le chef a dit : "Vous savez, cette opération
ne peut pas être menée paisiblement.
Il va y avoir des échanges de tirs.
Et donc il existe une forte probabilité,
qu'ils meurent par nos balles ou les leurs."
Une fois que Sharon a entendu ça,
il a donné l'ordre d'arrêter le plan.
Il a dit : "On en discute plus. On arrête."
Un seul avion aurait pu bombarder
son palais présidentiel,
et tout détruire.
Mais les Israéliens ne voulaient
pas endosser la responsabilité,
d'un tel assassinat
de manière aussi flagrante.
Mais à partir du moment
où il encerclait la Mouqata'a,
et qu'il contrôlait tout ce dont
Abou Ammar avait besoin,
de la bouteille d'eau
jusqu'aux médicaments,
il faut que vous le sachiez...
Ils ont été persuadés que la seule
façon de l'arrêter était de le tuer.
Il fallait le tuer de manière mystérieuse.
Et que ce mystère dure à jamais.
Je suis sûre que c'est
quelqu'un de l'intérieur,
qui a dû attendre les ordres,
le moment propice,
pour mettre ce grain de polonium,
dans la soupe ou dans un verre
de café ou de thé.
Il avait les ordres
de commettre le crime,
Ça c'est sûr.
Arafat n'était plus important.
Il était d'autant moins important qu'on
n'allait pas investir dans du polonium,
ou quelque chose d'aussi idiot.
Je peux vous dire d'une façon certaine,
que cette histoire d'empoisonnement
par Israël est un non-sens,
un véritable non-sens.
Tout le monde accuse Israël
mais je ne veux pas accuser Israël.
Pourquoi vous m'obligez à accuser Israël ?
C'est pas parce que je défends Israël,
parce que je veux des preuves.
Tout le monde accuse Israël.
Elle l'a fait et on ferme les yeux.
Merci, au revoir !
Pas question !
J'ai mis la justice pour que la justice
voit cette affaire.
Le 10 mars 2014, coup de théâtre.
Une nouvelle accusation est proférée.
Côté palestinien cette fois,
Mahmoud Abbas, Abou Mazen,
de son nom de guerre,
qui a succédé à Arafat à la présidence
de l'Autorité palestinienne,
désigne l'ancien chef de la sécurité à Gaza,
Mohammed Dahlan, d'avoir fait exécuter
des responsables palestiniens,
et joué un rôle dans la mort d'Arafat.
Six personnes ont été tuées
avec l'aval de Dahlan.
Une investigation a été menée.
On a tous les éléments de l'enquête.
Dahlan a déclaré à l'époque
que la mission d'Arafat était terminée.
Et qu'une nouvelle génération
était nécessaire.
Il y a eu des manifestations et des
déclarations publiques,
indiquant que le temps
d'Arafat était révolu,
et qu'il fallait du sang neuf.
Qui a tué Yasser Arafat ?
Je pense que tout cela, ce ne sont pas
des preuves, mais bien des indices.
Des indices qui méritent
d'être pris en compte.
Surtout que nous sommes impatients
de savoir quelle est la main,
qui a apporté le poison
à Yasser Arafat.
À la télévision, l'ancien responsable
de la sécurité à Gaza lui répond,
et clame son innocence.
Les Palestiniens se déchirent.
Chaque camp se renvoie la responsabilité
de la mort du président Palestinien.
Quelques mois avant sa mort, en 2004,
Arafat est de plus en plus isolé.
Tenu à l'écart par les siens qui
négocient sans qu'il en soit informé.
Sous la pression
de la communauté internationale,
le vieux, comme l'appellent affectueusement
ses fidèles, ne veut rien lâcher.
Il veut garder la main sur les services
de sécurité et sur les finances.
La corruption est partout.
Mais Arafat tient à son pouvoir.
Pour beaucoup, il devient gênant.
Le président Arafat
a eu beaucoup d'ennemis,
à l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur.
Mais encore une fois, je crois que la
démarche de sa veuve, c'est la vérité.
Dans la recherche de la vérité,
nous n'avons aucun préjugé,
nous n'avons aucun interdit,
nous n'avons aucun tabou.
Ce que nous souhaitons, c'est la vérité.
Et c'est l'enquête qui déterminera qui.
Qui avait intérêt ?
Qui avait intérêt à ce moment là ?
Qui ? Pourquoi ?
Je pense personnellement que la France,
connaît la cause de la mort
du président Arafat.
Je pense aussi que ce dossier,
est entre les mains
du gouvernement français,
avec comme mention "top secret".
Le crime profite à beaucoup de gens.
Il y a beaucoup de gens, de Palestiniens
qui n'aimaient pas Yasser.
Beaucoup de pays extremistes
Israël n'aimait pas Yasser.
Ça profite à beaucoup de gens parce
qu'on dit que c'était l'Amérique,
mais je ne peux pas accuser
qui que ce soit !
Quand on n'aime pas, ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on veut éliminer.
Mais ça profite aux gens qui ne veulent
pas la paix, qui veulent la guerre.
Aujourd'hui, Souha Arafat
et sa fille Zahwa, âgée de 19 ans,
attendent sur l'île de Malte
où elles résident,
les résultats de l'enquête
menée par la justice française.
Pour la fille de l'ancien président
de l'Autorité palestinienne,
la disparition de son père
est encore douloureuse,
et elle éprouve toujours aujourd'hui
des difficultés à en parler.
Le dossier de la mort de Yasser Arafat
n'est pas encore clos,
et la femme et la fille
du chef palestinien disparus,
sont bien décidés à poursuivre
leur combat pour la vérité.
Savoir qui avait intérêt à voir
disparaître le président palestinien.
Les Israéliens ? Les Palestiniens ?
Ou est-ce une conjonction d'intérêts
qui a conduit à sa disparition ?